"
>>> RUSSIA'S MILITARY SAID TO BE
DIVIDED TONIGHT OVER UKRAINE'S
STUNNING MILITARY OFFENSIVE,
RETAKING THOUSANDS OF SQUARE
MILES FROM MOSCOW'S FORCES,
WHICH ARE NOW ON THE DEFENSIVE
IN EASTERN AND SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
CNN'S SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MATTHEW CHANCE HAS
THE LATEST FOR US.
MATTHEW, CNN'S REPORTING THAT
PUTIN HIMSELF IS GIVING
DIRECTIONS TO GENERALS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AS RUSSIA'S MILITARY
APPEARS INCREASINGLY DIVIDED ON
HOW TO PROCEED WITH THIS WAR.
TELL US MORE OF WHAT YOU'RE
LEARNING.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, WOLF.
TONIGHT ANOTHER ILLUSTRATION OF
JUST HOW MUCH INTELLIGENCE U.S.
AUTHORITIES HAVE, THE U.S.
INTELLIGENCE HAS, ON THE
THINKING OF WHAT'S GOING ON
INSIDE THE RUSSIAN COMMAND
STRUCTURE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT INTERCEPTS
THAT THEY'VE SORT OF MADE
AVAILABLE TO CNN.
WE'RE REPORTING ON THAT.
ABOUT HOW THERE ARE
DISAGREEMENTS ON THE BATTLEFIELD
BETWEEN SENIOR OFFICERS IN THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY ABOUT WHAT THE
TACTICAL RESPONSE SHOULD BE IN
VARIOUS SCENARIOS.
THEY'VE BEEN FLUNG INTO DISARRAY
ACCORDING TO THESE INTERCEPTS
BECAUSE OF THE DRAMATIC ADVANCES
ON THE FIELD BY UKRAINIAN FORCES
IN THE NORTH OF THE COUNTRY
AROUND THE CITY OF KHARKIV, AND
THERE ARE INTERCEPTS LOOKING AT
RECORDING OFFICERS COMPLAINING
TO THEIR LOVED ONES AT HOME AND
TO THEIR FELLOW COLLEAGUES ABOUT
THE STRATEGIC DECISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE BY MOSCOW.
SO ALL OF THIS POINTS TO A SORT
OF CHAOTIC SORT OF MESS IF YOU
LIKE IN TERMS OF THE COMMAND
STRUCTURE.
MORE THAN THAT, THOUGH, THESE
U.S. INTERCEPTS SUGGEST THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN HIMSELF, THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, HAS BEEN
SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO AND GIVING
ORDERS DIRECTLY TO RUSSIAN
GENERALS IN THE FIELD.
NOW, THAT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY, IF YOU
LIKE, FOR A MODERN MILITARY LIKE
RUSSIA'S.
AND IT INDICATES -- FIRST OF
ALL, IT INDICATES A
DYSFUNCTIONAL COMMAND STRUCTURE,
BUT IT ALSO INDICATES THAT THE
MILITARY PLAN IN RUSSIA SUCH AS
IT EXISTS SEEMS TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE POLITICIANS, BY VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
IT INDICATES THAT THE STRATEGY
IS A POLITICAL ONE, NOT A
MILITARY ONE.
AND THAT MAY ACCOUNT FOR SOME OF
THE BATTLEFIELD LOSSES THAT THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY HAS SUFFERED
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
WOLF.
>> AND MATTHEW, ALL THIS COMES,
AS YOU WELL KNOW, AS THE
PRESSURE IS CLEARLY MOUNTING ON
PUTIN BACK HOME.
>> Reporter: YEAH, A LOT OF
PRESSURE MOUNTING ON HIM.
HE'S BEEN TRYING TO RAISE THE
STAKES BY ANNOUNCING REFERENDUMS
IN THE AREAS OF UKRAINE THAT
RUSSIA OCCUPIES.
BUT ACTUALLY THE STAKES HAVE
BEEN RAISED AT HOME BECAUSE HE'S
INTRODUCED A MOBILIZATION, HE
CALLS A PARTIAL MOBILIZATION OF
RESERVISTS, TRYING TO GET
300,000 RUSSIAN MEN WHO'VE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY INTO THE FORCES.
IT'S LEADING TO PROTESTS ON THE
STREETS, WITH MORE THAN 1300
PEOPLE DETAINED SO FAR.
THERE ARE DRAMATIC SCENES AT
BORDER CROSSINGS AROUND RUSSIA
AS MEN OF MILITARY AGE AND THEIR
FAMILY ATTEMPT TO ESCAPE THE
COUNTRY BEFORE THEY CAN BE SORT
OF SWEPT UP INTO THE ARMED
FORCES AND SENT TO THE FRONT
LINE.
BUT IT REALLY IS RATCHETING UP
PRESSURE ON VLADIMIR PUTIN AT
HOME.
>> BIG TIME INDEED.
MATTHEW CHANCE, THANK YOU VERY,
VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO TO UKRAINE RIGHT NOW
WHERE PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY TALKED ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN MOBILIZATION IN HIS
NIGHTLY ADDRESS TO HIS NATION.
CNN'S SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT BEN WEDEMAN IS ON
THE SCENE FOR US TONIGHT.
BEN, HOW IS UKRAINE REACTING TO
NEWS OF THIS RUSSIAN
MOBILIZATION?
>> Reporter: WELL, FIRST, JUST
AS YOUR SHOW BEGAN, WOLF, THE
AIR RAID SIREN WENT OFF HERE.
AS FAR AS THE REACTION,
ZELENSKYY ACTUALLY WAS MAKING
HIS NIGHTLY SPEECH TODAY.
AND NORMALLY IT'S IN UKRAINIAN.
IT STARTED IN UKRAINIAN.
AND THEN HE SWITCHED TO RUSSIAN,
ADDRESSING THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE
DIRECTLY.
HE SAID THAT THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
A PARTIAL MOBILIZATION IS A
FRANK ADMISSION THAT THE RUSSIAN
ARMY HAS FAILED IN UKRAINE.
HE SAID THAT RUSSIANS WHO HAVE
DONE NOTHING TO RESIST THE WAR
ARE ACCOMPLICES IN WAR CRIMES
AND TORTURE IN UKRAINE.
HE WENT ON TO SAY FOR INSTANCE
THAT IT IS TIME TO CHOOSE, FOR
RUSSIAN MEN IT'S TO CHOOSE
WHETHER TO DIE OR BE CRIPPLED OR
TO SURVIVE.
FOR RUSSIAN WOMEN IT'S TIME TO
EITHER LET THEIR SONS, THEIR
HUSBANDS, THEIR GRANDCHILDREN
DIE OR TO LET THEM SURVIVE.
HE NOTED THAT ACCORDING TO THE
UKRAINIANS 55,000 RUSSIANS HAVE
BEEN KILLED SINCE THIS WAR BEGAN
LAST FEBRUARY.
AND THAT THEIR CHOICES -- THEY
HAVE A CHOICE, EITHER TO
PROTEST, TO FIGHT BACK, TO RUN
AWAY, OR IF THEY'RE IN UKRAINE
TO SURRENDER TO UKRAINIAN
FORCES.
WOLF?
>> BEN WEDEMAN REPORTING FOR US.
BEN, THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH.
LET'S GET SOME MORE ON ALL OF
THESE DRAMATIC DEVELOPMENTS.
JOINING US RIGHT NOW, CNN'S
CHIEF INTERNATIONAL ANCHOR
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR.
CHRISTIANE, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
THIS RUSSIAN MOBILIZATION, AS
YOU WELL KNOW, MAY BE A
DESPERATE MOVE BY PUTIN, BUT IS
IT A SIGN HE'S DIGGING IN ON
THIS WAR?
>> THIS IS WHAT THE EUROPEANS
AND AMERICANS AND BASICALLY
WESTERN ALLIANCE PEOPLE ARE
TELLING ME HERE AT THE U.N.
I SPOKE TO THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION PRESIDENT, URSULA VON
DER LEYEN.
SHE BELIEVES, AND SO DO OTHERS
I'VE SPOKEN TO, THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW SHOWS A MEASURE OF
DESPERATION.
AND WHAT YOU'VE JUST HEARD FROM
BEN AND FROM MATTHEW REGARDING
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE GROUND IS
TESTAMENT TO THAT, THAT PUTIN IF
HE REALLY IS CALLING UP GENERALS
ON THE FRONT AND DIRECTING, YOU
KNOW, FROM THE KREMLIN BUNKER
THIS IS NOT HOW MODERN WAR IS
WAGED.
IN ADDITION, ANY MOBILIZATION IS
BEING PROTESTED RIGHT NOW BUT
WOULD TAKE TIME TO ACTUALLY
STAND UP INCLUDING TRAINING AND
GETTING THEM READY TO ACTUALLY
GO INTO BATTLE.
THE EU HAS SAID THAT THEY WILL
BE IMPOSING A NEW ROUND OF
SANCTIONS IN RETALIATION FOR
ANY, QUOTE, SHAM ELECTIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO TAKE PLACE
ACCORDING TO PUTIN IN THE
RUSSIAN-OCCUPIED PARTS OF
UKRAINE.
AND THAT IS MEANT TO BE
STARTING, THESE SHAM ELECTIONS,
TOMORROW.
FOR THEIR PART THE UKRAINIANS
ARE SAYING NOW IS THE TIME TO
GIVE US THE WEAPONRY WE NEED TO
MAKE GOOD ON THE PROGRESS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY MADE AND TO HELP
US KEEP TERRITORY AND KEEP